Sandy Shores is a quiet
town to the ls city Folk it's nothing
more than a few broken down Shacks in
the desert to the locals it's
worse but perhaps the biggest cowpie on
all the reputation of Sandy Shores is
the legend of the infinity
murders
if you're familiar with GTA Easter eggs
you may have heard about this one before
but I can almost guarantee you you
haven't heard the whole story out of all
the YouTube videos I watched while
researching this topic I haven't seen
one who actually uncovered how deep this
Rabbit Hole goes we'll start with the
surface level the story as it's been
told so
far abandoned near the base of Mount
Chiliad at this location on the map lie
the remains of a scorched house painted
on the wall perhaps in blood there will
be eight above it a strange symbol of
some kind remember this on the east
facing wall another message go away
meral Abrahams you're a wrong surrounded
by eights how curious also found in the
house are jars containing What appear to
be assorted body parts hanging running
shoes tally marks the message 8 is just
Infinity stood up and a couple blocks
down the road a newspaper clipping that
reads as follows Merl Abrahams the
suspected Infinity killer passed away
last night in Bowling Brook Penitentiary
while awaiting trial for abduction and
torture Abrahams 57 was suspected to be
responsible for the infinity murders a
series of disappearances that happened 5
years ago police believed the eight
victims who were all single young men
killed while jogging were all murdered
by the same person and had
circumstantial evidence linking Mr
Abraham's to the victims no body were
ever found and Mr Abrahams never
confessed although he did admit to a
weird obsession with the number eight
just a few blocks away written in a
familiar script on a rock a nursery
rhyme is found one is done two was fun
three tried to run four called Mom
five's not alive six is Nicks Seven's in
heaven eight won't wait a bit further
south on another rock
they want me they can have but they'll
never get my people even though I shall
leave them sign enough where they put me
this cryptic message suggests that the
bodies will never be found despite the
killer planning to leave a clue at the
prison to which he will inevitably be
taken and of course he didn't fail to
deliver inside Bowling Brook
Penitentiary scrolled on the wall reads
where water meets land and fire once
spewed forth there the infinite eight
shall stay until I return and again that
strange symbol is drawn hold on pause
zoom in on that Peninsula at the very
north of the map now overlay the mystery
symbol yep we got
him sure enough upon closer inspection
all eight of the missing bodies can be
found in the water around this area
wrapped in plastic and lying undisturbed
and presumably undiscovered on the sea
Flor all of the information that I just
discussed was discovered very quickly as
evidenced by this thread by GTA forums
user an evil vat that lays it all out
this was posted just 10 days after the
game released in 2013 and for a while
that's where people thought it ended I
don't know how to transition into this
bit so I'm just going to Eddie low is a
rather minor character in GTA 4 only
appearing in a couple Random Encounters
in the first encounter Nico finds Eddie
in a shady alley where he asks Nico for
a ride to the docks to drop off his
friend hey there pal hey they talk for a
while until the conversation takes a
weird turn so maybe it's the
masturbating maybe that's God's real
gift to us okay I'd really like to get
back to planet Earth so maybe I'll see
you later no wait I have this rather
heavy bag and I really need a lift I can
pay
you okay okay thanks I'm Eddie by the
way Eddie low yes fine come
on you mind taking us down to the docks
you're going some where I'm not going
anywhere my friends are though they're
heading
off after the encounter this broadcast
can be heard from the in-game news
station weasel news weasel news Liberty
City remains Under Siege as another body
was found this time at the Liberty ferry
terminal in Alder City a decapitated
jogger who was getting fit in the wrong
place at the wrong time detect John
ainson has been working the case a thank
God he did it again I was beginning to
lose my media profile we'll be making an
arrest soon how's my hair look this
might be a good time to mention that
Eddie is canonically a serial killer the
GTA Wiki goes into great detail about
his childhood trauma and subsequent
atrocities but I'll skip it here all
that you need to know is that he's
basically every serial killer stereotype
rolled up into one in the second
encounter after making a number of
disturbing comments toward Nico do you
like to get spanked like that excuse me
Eddie is told that you should get l or
something to which he responds oh I just
did a little jogger down by the water
but you know what handsome I got a
hunger tonight that can't be seed it
come here Nico ends up killing Eddie in
self-defense now you may be thinking so
he's a serial killer what does this have
to do with the infinity murders way down
in San Andreas and that's a a fair
question Eddie is far from the first
serial killer in the GTA Cannon and
besides throwing bodies into water isn't
exactly a unique calling card but
remember that letter back in Sandy
Shores said that Merl killed joggers so
does Eddie low a decapitated jogger who
was getting fit in the wrong place at
the wrong time a little jogger down by
the
[Music]
water you know how I said Eddie was the
first serial killer in GTA Cannon I
wasn't lying that tradition goes all the
way back to the old
west during a mission Arthur
investigates a serial killer known for
you guessed it decapitating his
victims and if that isn't enough way
back in Red Dead Redemption 1 you can
find this scrolled on a rock in Prima
kada I don't understand
infin Infinity T typos aside it looks
like we've found yet another individual
who is obsessed with writing on rocks
about infinity and you know what the
handwriting looks pretty damn similar to
The Infinity killer in GTA 5 but the
piece of evidence that finally
solidified the connection between him
Eddie and the infinity killer as Canon
for me was this newspaper clipping from
Red Dead 2 which states that Edmund
killed the Blackwater Athletics team
while they were on a run it turns out
their bodies can actually be found in
game he hated Runners just like Eddie
just like the infinity
killer oh and one thing I forgot to
mention in the GTA timeline we have
Eddie low right well the killer in Red
Dead is named Edmund Edmund Lowry
[Music]
junr
as a warning from this point there's
some heavy speculation on my part there
are lots of theories floating around
that conflict with this one some of
which are linked in the description but
I think this is the strongest
explanation So based on all the evidence
I've just presented here's my best
timeline of events the Lowes later
simplified to the low's are a family
with a multi-generational tradition of
Serial murdering those who dare to jog
among many others the tradition goes
back to at least the year 1899 when Red
Dead Redemption 2 takes place then 3 or
four generations later in 1999 Eddie low
shocks the town of Sandy Shores by
committing the infinity murders but he
doesn't do it alone he either threatens
or coerces Merl Abrahams into being the
Fall Guy how does he do this well I have
a theory in the second encounter with
Eddie low in GTA 4 Eddie is going on a
rant speaking in the third person and
directly addressing the parents of his
various victims well Mrs Smith Eddie's
taking your star son your prized little
quarterback and [__] him in the ass
and then tied him up strangled him into
knots and your daughter you pretty
little daughter Mrs Abraham's and he's
ripped out her intestines just to see if
he could feel anything and you know what
he couldn't he couldn't at one point he
mentions a surname we've heard before
your pretty little daughter Mrs
Abraham's Abraham Abraham Abraham
perhaps this Miss Abrahams is actually
the wife of Merl Abrahams and low was
just using their daughter's life as a
bargaining chip to secure someone to
frame for the murders kind of a you take
the fall or your daughter gets it type
of deal this would explain how the
handwriting on the notes remains
consistent inside the prison even though
Eddie low was never locked up and likely
wouldn't have had access inside the
prison Merl was just the one riding them
the whole time it's possible that Merl
was also the one carrying out the
murders although there's no real
evidence for this and besides Eddie's
only real character trait is that he
enjoys violence why would he pass pass
up an opportunity for a bit of
refreshing Slaughter anyway Merl
Abrahams is locked up for crimes
orchestrated by Eddie low and as the
2004 newspaper clipping States dies in
prison despite all moral sacrifice to
save his daughter Eddie gruesomely kills
her
anyway why in his own words just to see
if he could feel something sometime
between 1999 and 2008 when GTA 4 takes
place Eddie moves to Liberty City where
he commits a total of 10 more murders
before he's killed by Nico in a knife
fight the
end now that I've wrapped this story up
neatly in a little bow I have to tell
you something there's something I've
been hiding a piece of evidence that
keeps me up at
night when the community discovered
those bodies scattered around pedo Bay
they thought it was solved the bodies
for the infinity murders had been cast
off into the sea and forgotten case
closed but in April of 201 2015 GTA 5
was released for the PC with the game's
inner workings now being much more
accessible mod menus were quickly
developed and Easter egg hunters wasted
no time poking around PLO Bay for clues
that had been missed as it turns out
they struck gold there are two different
models used between all eight of the
underwater bodies somehow these modders
figured out that if you spawn in a piece
of glass the wrap covering the bodies
doesn't render through it and written on
the bodies in that same red handwriting
the number eight
so that's confirmation that these bodies
are related to the infinity murders and
Rockstar knew that people are still
curious enough to look but hold on the
infinity killer targeted eight male
joggers and as you can tell by the black
bars I had to add these are definitely
not males so that uh throws a wrench
into things just to get it out of the
way there's always the possibility that
this was an oversight by Rockstar or
they're just trying to [__] with us by
throwing in a red herring but we're
going to operate under the assumption
that this was an intentional clue that
leaves us with the possibility that
Eddie L simply killed more than the main
eight he kept yapping about perhaps he
stuck around for a while after Abrahams
was locked up and kept on killing right
there in Sandy Shores and this is a
totally separate set of victims but that
doesn't feel complete to me from a
narrative perspective there's a whole
mystery leading up to you finding these
eight bodies only for you to find a
totally separate set of eight bodies
unrelated to the murder you've been
investigating there has to be something
bigger going on
on GTA's most famous puzzle is known as
the Chiliad mystery and it centers
around a mural found at the peak of
Mount Chiliad the lore goes incredibly
deep and it involves UFOs cultists time
travel government conspiracies Bigfoot
and other tantalizing elements I
couldn't possibly summarize the Chiliad
mystery in this video it's way too
complex but I can recommend a great
analysis by Source Brew which should be
popping up in the top right of the video
if you want to go down the rabbit hole
for now just know that the Chiliad
mystery is a supernatural government
conspiracy that the Easter egg hunting
Community has been chipping away at for
nearly a decade but what does this have
to do with the infinite 8 well the case
has been made that the infinite 8
mystery is connected to the mural on
Chiliad post like this present some
interesting theories but the more
compelling evidence is what they do not
want you to
know.com
what they do not want you to know.com is
a website that you can access using a
computer in GTA 4 it's only accessible
after the story is complete and it
contains cheat sheet maps for some of
the collectible missions throughout the
game one of the maps is posted by you
guessed it Eddie low it's titled fun
with friends and the description
indicates that this is where Eddie marks
the location of every time he has found
people enjoying themselves together
don't ask me what he meant by that I
don't know I don't [__] want to know
anyway I visited some of these locations
but I wasn't able to find anything out
of the ordinary nothing written in blood
no obvious instances of the number eight
I'm honestly not sure what you're
supposed to find at these markers so let
me know in the comments if you have any
ideas but here's where it connects to
the Chiliad mystery as far as I can tell
what they do not want you to know.com
doesn't come up in search results on the
in-game browser I find to access it you
have to either type the link in directly
or wait until you've completed the story
at which point you'll receive an email
from a mysterious stranger with a link
to the site that mysterious stranger's
username Chiliad a
8888 if you're still not convinced I
have one final piece of evidence that
the infinite 8 mystery goes deeper than
it appears this is what's known as the
Doomsday mural the single image around
which a significant amount of the
Chiliad mystery discourse has revolved
for the last few years yeah so they have
two different mystery murals that
they're obsessed with it gets very
confusing during the finale of the
Doomsday DLC the player visits a secret
launch facil facility inside of Mount
Chiliad where these murals can be seen
bordering these balconies once the
community got a hold of the texture they
began looking for the meanings of all
these little symbols that make up the
different sections of the wall what they
discovered is that each of these colors
represent a different facet of the
Mysteries that have been investigated
over the years by the community the
green section refers to the Bigfoot
peyote Easter egg which took the
community years to solv due to the
insane conditions that need to be met in
order to trigger it along with needing
to be in a certain spot in the early
morning on a foggy day with a 100% game
save you also must have previously
collected all 27 peyote plants hidden
around the map then and only then can
you collect the final golden peyote and
play as Bigfoot navigating your way
toward a final boss fight with a monster
known as the Beast as far as I know this
is the last mission in the entire game
now back to the mural remember how I
said you have to collect 27 peyote
plants the number 27 is prominently
featured here on the mural just a above
the diagram of a man evolving into
Bigfoot you can see why the Easter egg
hunting Community was so excited finally
their patience with these convoluted
Easter eggs was being acknowledged but
the green section is the only part of
the mural whose corresponding mystery
has already been solved the rest are
very much ongoing investigations the
purple section for instance contains a
reference to the logo of in-game
psychologist Dr friedlander Who many
believe is involved in a whole other can
of worms known as as the karma mystery
The yellow section is pretty clearly
about the Chiliad mystery as evidenced
by the mural setion going on here which
illustrates that very same cryptic
diagram which has been at the center of
the Chiliad mystery since the beginning
again unsolved and finally we turn our
attention to the red mural which
contains large and unmistakably
[Music]
infinity I'm honestly not sure what to
make of all this information it's been
over 5 years since the Doom day DLC was
released and the green section Still
Remains the only section of the mural to
actually have been solved to any
satisfying degree do these individual
Mysteries actually share connective
tissue or is Rockstar just trolling
everybody and stoking the fire by
echoing the community's own delusions
back at it I don't know one thing's for
sure though the infinite 8 story is far
more than just a self-contained murder
mystery that's why I'm relying on you to
go out and do some research of your own
investigate those marked locations in
GTA 4 scr the wikies and the subreddits
for anything I may have missed or you
could just go outside shut
[Music]
up